okay now this is what I want to do I
want to talk about the women that sell
dreams because it builds a brand now as
you guys know Twitter I just go crazy on
Twitter that's my thing I love Twitter
um that's my Twitter pearly things go
follow it I'm trying to get to 400k you
know what's crazy guys I started off at
like 20K like six months ago I'm almost
at 325 look it I killed the Twitter game
so this is a chick named um Elita and um
it says Amala Clooney Met George Clooney
at 35 the love of her life this was her
speech to him according to Red Pill
Twitter she should have married he
should have married an 18 year old
virgin whilst cheating on her every now
and then love will find it when you
least expect it if you're open to it can
we play the video I Met George when I
was 35 and starting to become quite
resigned to the idea that I was going to
be a spinster
then we met
started hiding out in my London flat and
very soon it felt like no matter what
happened I would never want to be with
anyone else
I couldn't sleep when we were apart and
I'm told that I would display a
particular grin and head tilt when
reading his text messages or the letters
that he would hide in my bag
five years later none of that has
changed
he is the person who has my complete
admiration and also the person who smile
makes me melt every time
my love
what I have found with you is the great
love that I always hoped existed and
seeing you with our children Ella and
Alexander is the greatest joy in my life
you fill our home with laughter and
happiness and that's even before the
children have worked out that Dada is
actually Batman a talking Fox and
Friends with Mary Poppins
I am so proud of you my love
congratulations on this great honor that
you're receiving tonight I am proud of
you but I also know that when our
children find out not only what you have
done but who you are they will be so
proud of you too
shaming us for living in reality okay
and selling dreams for money now I don't
really know who this chick is so nothing
personal please don't go on a Twitter
rant about how mean I am I'm criticizing
the idea not you now all right
so she's I want to break down what she's
saying Amala Met George Clooney at 35
the love of her life and this was her
speech to him according to Red Pill
Twitter he should have married an 18
year old virgin while cheating on her
every now and then
no that's not what I say that's what as
as a chick in the red pill that's not
what I say I say and this is the thing
what they'll do is the women they can't
process things with logic so they'll be
like ah I'm so emotional and then
they'll just be like well they said he
should only marry an 18 year old virgin
no no I said virgins are better and
younger women are better there's
exceptions right and this is what I said
women will sell dreams that really only
happen for exceptionally beautiful
models because it sounds nice now again
this sounds amazing it's not reality and
we're constantly being pandered to
um yeah and like I'm really happy you
know it seems like they have a good
marriage so I would never say that he
should have went with an 18 year old
model he seems to find what works for
him
um but the point is that Amal got this
because she's really really hot hot
women get you know special privileges
and the truth of the matter is most
women that follow her and that listen to
me are average I'm an average chick most
women are average and the truth of the
matter is at 35 your odds of getting
married as a chick is like 15 you know
if you get to 30 it's like your odds of
getting married is like 20 if you're a
single mother your odds of getting
married is like 10 13. I'm this is rough
estimates right but
so I could say women it'll be you when
the truth of the matter is
in My Generation
Um it's really not gonna be us and
really
um the the Next Generation should just
learn from our generation that this is
going downhill
um let's take mine they're predicting
half of us will be single and childless
so that's 50 right then let's take the
other half that do get married half of
those will get divorced
that's three out of four we'll have not
fairy tale endings three out of four of
us will die alone that means you're more
likely to be the rule than the exception
and selling this dream that it's gonna
work out for you
instead of saying look it let's take
this l
and and at least be honest to the Next
Generation and say hey get married young
don't become an old spinster like this
chick you're probably not gonna get
George Clooney that certainly is not
happening for you chica like imagine
imagine okay imagine okay her
that's right her and
her at George Clooney married a model
that
it's like okay
and then look doesn't even that doesn't
even take into account
who is gonna be in the room with George
cloon like
and so then they'll they'll this is what
they'll do I'll live in reality and I'll
say look
um guys I'm just being honest it's not
gonna it's not gonna end well for most
of us
um really again we should just be honest
with the Next Generation and if I was a
guy I would just pass up these old
chicks I'd pass up and I'd go get a 21
year old and take away your phone
because this is going great like that's
what I would do
and and she'd probably be happier too
you know social media makes us depressed
you know it's like that's that if I was
a guy that's what I would do or I would
just not deal with women at all and
that's what a lot of guys are picking
and and this is what they'll do they'll
say well you're a doomsday or Pearl
you're just the big meanie and I and I
look and honestly guys
we're in a post-marriage society
uh the Trad cons really haven't caught
up yet but marriage isn't marriage
anymore it doesn't exist it's gone
um under 40 how many couples do you know
that have been married 10 years and and
that's really where I see the
generational shift is like okay the 40
to 60 year olds roughly was the last
generation of shitty wives yup yeah yeah
so actually I'm gonna break this down a
little further so what I found is the 60
to 80 year old women
they had a shitty mindset but they were
okay wives so they cooked you know they
cleaned they they did they they knew
they were supposed to be like like with
their husband they didn't get divorced
many separated but didn't divorce
um there were some divorces that was
like the beginning of the end right but
they had really bad mindsets they felt
like we should have 50 50 like 50 it's
equal they didn't really believe in
obeying their husband if you look at
that like there's little telltale signs
that you can tell like if you look at
the house is it his house or her house
typically it would be her house what she
wanted and the family dynamic in the
home a lot of times was what she wanted
and you know they would kick kick out
their husbands over stupid reasons like
money or whatever like it's like even
though he brought home all the money she
felt like she needed to be in control of
it like stuff like this because this is
when the propaganda really like hit that
generation heavy
so generation one shitty mindset and
they told their daughters to always have
a backup plan they told their daughters
to go to work they often trash talked
their husbands to their daughters so now
and women again it's the same propaganda
method oh here's a scary story fear fear
fear so that and all those women they
run to work and that's the first
generation the 40 to like roughly 60
year olds generation of truly shitty
wives that's like the generation before
could still cook they could still clean
they could you know they still had like
skills but the next generation was just
like God awful like they just they they
really couldn't like cook or clean I
mean they maybe knew a little bit from
childhood but they didn't really
teach their daughters anything or their
son well the men are good people so
they'll still teach their sons more so
than the women but yeah and so then the
40 to 60 year olds that's like the real
generation of Devore like that they ruin
marriage to be honest and I would argue
maybe up to 65. the the women that I
I've interviewed and stuff that have a
more like real like good mindset where
they obey their men seems to be like the
80 to 100 year olds
guys how crazy is that so we've had one
on one not two but three generations of
shitty wives and what does this mean
what does this mean for us this means
that a lot of times skills get lost in
three generations and I really think
that the skills of being a wife has been
lost in three generations so much so
that
do you know what's really funny what's
really interesting how much women like
Miss the point because what they'll do
is they'll focus on like like you'll see
these women selling femininity right and
a lot of these femininity courses and a
lot of it is based on looks it's based
on these like rules for the men like
these 90-day rules
at its core femininity it's not about
the way you look it's it's not about
um etiquette
it's not about your career what what
femininity is about is serving others
it's obeying that is true femininity do
you think our ancestors were farmers
okay do you think the women on the farm
were that worried about their Botox
Nails the fake hair
no that's like putting a Band-Aid over
the real problem and the real problem is
the generation before us was a
generation of shitty selfish wives and
they taught us to go to college and
focus on our career they taught us that
we were more important they taught us
happy wife happy life they taught us
that it's all about balance that you
should have a say when the truth of the
matter is that men built this world men
run this world and men should run their
households and it's all propaganda and
it's wrong and these femininity coaches
come in and they just try to control the
men in a different way when the truth of
the matter is true femininity
is exerting zero control over the men in
your lives that's that's what made
marriages work and the funny thing is um
the Trad concerts will revert to
while women used to be at home
not really women were out in the fields
working
and this idea that women didn't work is
the dumbest I've ever heard of
women have always worked they had
exceptionally hard lives I think we
would die the women today I would die if
I had to live life like a chick a
hundred years ago they'd get up they
would milk the cows they would be in the
garden they would tow the fields like
they were helping their family but the
point was they would all come together
and it was for the family not themselves
that's true femininity and when you
think of this and let's bring this into
real life the women that you know maybe
it's a grandmother maybe it's a great
grandmother those women that are truly
like feminine right when you think of
like the most high quality women you
know
are they focused on makeup and hair and
all of that stuff or were they so
selfless that everybody around them
loved them were they so selfless that
they have these recipes that they come
in and you just feel like you're at home
that's that's what true femininity is
but the problem is we have all these
women trying to make money and profit
that get a ring but are just disguise
and I call them the disguised wives they
look like a wife they seem like a wife
they have the ring like a wife but they
don't act like a wife and I saw this
when I tweeted
um on conservative Twitter I said happy
wife happy life with a barfing emoji and
the entire tradcon said well it's about
balance well what about what she wants
like you should get wisdom from your
wives no guys that's feminism the
natural order of the world it's supposed
to go God men women children you are not
supposed to exert control over your
husband it's his program that and and
guys
this is the only way I see it work and
and you know when the women when it
becomes one of these balanced these
quote unquote balanced relationships
this is what I see
um it's really just what the woman wants
it's never a balance because men are
generally content they're not really
going to complain they just kind of take
it and women will always complain and
will always whine that's just what we do
and Men of previous generations knew
that and they would keep us in check but
the problem is we give them no Authority
and we say that women are the Smart Ones
really these on only fans are
the Smart Ones
come on like and this is silly and it
and you really can see the mindset of
what and this is the thing guys truly
feminine wives actually don't get mad
about this stuff and I'll tell you why
because I I know women
um that really were Housewives and
really believed they obeyed their
husband they wanted when he came home
they didn't want him to lift a finger
okay now you know that's not the
reputation of wives today and those
women hadn't had have had an extremely
hard time because their friends would
shame them their friends just don't get
it so when I say that's the generation
of shitty wives they don't get mad they
say I know because I've been alone they
are lonely they don't have this gut
reaction and say oh well that's not all
women no they know it doesn't apply to
them and they they it's it's like it's a
very lonely life for women that truly
want to be traditional you know what
their friends will say that you're
you're being controlled even Christian
wives will say oh she's just his she
just does whatever he says and
that's they don't realize that's the way
it's supposed to be your husband isn't
supposed to ask your permission your
husband can do whatever he wants with
the money true submission is giving him
complete control and not trying to
control him I'm not saying chicks got to
do this for every single guy but what
what I am saying is uh if you do not do
that we're not perfect right so no no
chick's gonna do that perfectly but if
we can't even agree that that is the aim
that is the goal then the next
generation is going to be even shittier
wise but the problem is we have all
these wives that we're supposed to learn
from that don't even have the mindset of
the wife it's not even about working
right like my great grandma she she
married
um she married a baker right and she was
a nurse that's a quote unquote higher
status job and do you know what she did
she still gave him three meals a day and
she worked it's not about working guys
it's not even about working inside or
outside of the home it's about
everything is the family first
everything is your husband first it's
not about you and that's that's our
problem is social media has has made us
women live in this complete delusion and
narcissism where we think our career is
the most important thing and this is why
I say real traditional women
um get married before 25 the real the
real the real deals and I'll explain why
because they think it's important to
give their husband their most fertile
and Youthful years they know that's
important to men they want to give their
husband the best of them that's why they
wait until they're married to have sex
that's why and that those are the women
that were raised to truly be traditional
they're rare they barely they they are
almost damn near extinct but the only
way that we could ever come back from
that is if we agree on what the goal is
and the problem is women we we can't
even agree we will and whine
whenever I say hey that's that's the
best type of wives and then you have
women like this that come in and sell
you dreams that don't exist the truth of
the matter is Our Generation
Um
25 to 35 year old women most of us
aren't going to have a happy ending
um but really what we should do is talk
to the younger women and be honest with
them and tell them what the goal is
because the other issue too with women
that marry young is that they feel like
they're missing out
because our generation tells them they
are can you imagine that women get
married and have children and and our
generation of women
says to them that you're missing out you
need to hold off do all these things
first
and women are so easily misled and the
problem is now we've given women
Authority the ultimate Authority and for
whatever reason when women have a lot of
choice we just choose
destruction